we're here at Gary Dora Elementary
kicking off the chess cops program it's
a partnership between st. Louis police
departments st. Louis area schools and
the st. Louis chess club it introduces
officers to the game of chess and allows
them to go out into the community and
have a chance to play against some of
the best and brightest kids in st. Louis
it's really encouraging to see this
really large turnout I think it's the
largest turnout we've had for chess cops
event thus far so it's really
encouraging well this is a great program
I can't think of all the things we're
doing the Chess Club and there are a lot
of great things this one I think is the
most important for the community in the
city and the region because it gets
children together with police officers
in a very positive setting and I think
it's going to educate both of them and
it's going to cement relationships
between the police and the communities
now they get to see police officers in
the light they've never experienced now
when they see one they can think chess
they can think funny I think it's just
astonishing really you get this
contribution in the community I think
it's going to build bridges
it's gonna bring people together is
gonna bring the police officers together
with the young people and then the whole
community is gonna rally around it so
it's gonna have just a transformative
effect on the community I think the kids
get to interact on a one-on-one basis
with the police officer in a friendly
environment and also they're getting
benefits of the game of chess and I
think it bodes well for the future
getting more kids into the stem areas
science and math things like that so I
think the kids benefit in a variety of
ways police officer you expect to be
good
even my and managed to beat them like I
say because I'm only 12 not being like
people who start me as though it feels
bad because I you see them but something
like it's eating and stuff maybe you say
oh I'll play them the game of chess when
they see how the good a are it's so
police officer that you don't know at
all instead of your friends at school it
was fun playing the police officers
because some of them was good some of
them wasn't and some of them had very
good mood I never learned for and to
give the kids an opportunity to see the
police not as adversaries but really as
opponent and fun games mental so they're
building this relationship over sports
and you don't get to see that anywhere
else in the world and for me to come
this morning and witness it it's been an
amazing experience I hope I can bring it
back to my country I hope for the
program to expand and again to serve the
entire community in the entire region
just to increase the number of officers
and number of schools involved and
ultimately this breakfast and this event
is all about exposing our children to
the leaders of the community and to the
game of chess so it's showing how our
students are able to be what they see if
they're able to see great leadership if
they were to see great thinkers and they
can be great thinkers and they can
become great leaders chess has such
amazing benefits for young people and to
see the bridges being built here you
have to hope it's going to sow the seeds
for more community engagement in cities
around the country
today was an amazing day we're happy
that we're able to kick this program off
and we really look forward to what it
will bring
[Music]